so how optimistic are the foreign
secretaries supporters feeling well
let's get the view now of one of them
the Attorney General Sue Ella brafman
who joins me now very good morning to
you good morning let me just start by
asking you about an article you've
written in today's daily mail you've uh
got pretty angry in that article about
what you describe as the woke Orthodoxy
of diversity equality and inclusion and
you're particularly aiming your fire at
diversity officers and training but
doesn't diversity benefit institutions
like the Civil Service
I'm all for a diverse Workforce I'm all
for meritocracy I'm all for inclusion
those are good things in our society in
Britain as a real champion of those
values what I've been very dismayed by
however is the Takeover uh by HR teams
by campaign groups which have propagated
a political ideology when it comes to
Identity politics and that's what my
article is about we've seen thousands of
hours a huge cost to the taxpayers spent
on diversity and inclusion training and
it's been divisive not inclusive it's
been patronizing not empowering it's
based on an assumption that me as a an
ethnic Asian woman from working class
Roots must be a victim necessarily
oppressed that's a misassumption and I
think it creates division it creates uh
it's tearing the society tearing up our
society breaking down the fabric of our
country and I think it's a waste of
money but that supporters would say
they're exactly what's needed to promote
the diversity you say is so badly needed
no I disagree I think the way it's
taught and the way it's trained is uh
indoctrinating I think that it's uh the
training materials that I've seen uh
used in The Civil Service uh is a
riddled with left-wing uh views on race
and gender things like white privilege
uh civil servants are taught about
microaggressions they're taught about
white fragility they're taught about how
to be a straight Ally I don't think
those are objectively impartial when it
comes to politics and I don't think
they're good value for money and I don't
think ultimately that's what taxpayers
want their civil servants or their
government lawyers to be spending their
time on your attorney general how
important do you think that equality
laws and anti-discrimination practices
are oh wholly important absolutely this
country has made massive strides in the
field of uh quality and human rights and
that was a really proud record on
supporting people who have been uh you
know had grievances in in society and in
the workplace we've got a very good
track Britain is one of the best places
in the world to be a woman to be an
ethnic minority to be a gay person we
have a great record on rights and
equalities let's Champion that now let's
not keep creating division but does this
not send out the wrong message then if
we want to Champion that and are you
concerned that there are reports that
members of the LGBT plus conservative
group are questioning their future in
the party because of this anti-work
message not at all I think actually the
conservative party has an end of your
track record we're the party that
introduced and legislated for same-sex
marriage something that I would have
voted for something I'm very very proud
of in this country and that it was a
conservative prime minister and uh that
led the way on that I think that we're
very inclusive in our party and actually
our recent leadership campaign demons
Straits the modern diverse meritocratic
conservative party that we are we're a
party in which whatever your personal
characteristic it's about the tal your
talent and your ability to do the job
that really counts I mean it's a movie
like there's going to be even popular
you've said that it's it's going to be
money saving you talked about it being
12 million pounds of saving but the
latest poll that we've been talking
about this morning so it's just six
percent of britons think that reducing
the size of the Civil Service should be
a priority this isn't even a vote winner
is it
it's not really about being a vote
winner this is about making government
work well for the British people are you
going to appeal to the public aren't you
well we've got to do our job we've got
to deliver on our Manifesto commitments
and we've got to do that in the best
possible way in uh with at the best
value for money and the civil service is
too large we are bloated and that's why
this prime minister and both leadership
candidates have been supportive of
reducing the size of State Liz truss
instantly he's been very very strong on
trying to cut out waste in Whitehall cut
out uh the quangos reduce the
regulations reduce the diversity and
inclusion training which doesn't really
serve a material person but the point
I'm making is the poll suggests that
people generally don't think it should
be a huge priority they might say the
cost of living is a huge priority for
them by contrast and at a time when
we're we're going through that and also
there are tensions overseas as well
you've chosen to write an article in the
mail which is anti-woke is that really
your biggest priority I wouldn't say
necessary describe as anti-workout I'd
say is against uh offices and it's
against identity politics and the
divisive nature of uh of this uh this
trend that we're seeing in our corporate
and public sector but uh ultimately I
think this issue of the day that's why
you've chosen I think it's the biggest
issue today I think the biggest issue of
the day is how we support families and
businesses with the cost of living and
that's why when that's been the priority
of this campaign for the leader of the
party and it's a by far the most
important issues how we take a muscular
stance against Vladimir Putin it's about
how we deliver uh public services but
what what's important about this Civil
Service issue is that when it comes to
issuing passports on time when it comes
to getting people's driving licenses to
them in a in a prompt nature it comes to
Civil Service efficiency it comes to
government delivery and if we can reduce
the cost of civil service to reduce the
cost of government that's only not only
good for the economy and public spending
it's also really good for efficiency and
Public Service delivery for individuals
okay you say that the economy is is one
of your priorities and Liz truss's
priorities well the bank of England is
expected to put up interest rates today
possibly as much as by half of one
percent that would be the biggest rise
for 27 years Liz truss has made a lot of
spending commitments she wants to cut
taxes so the tune of around 30 billion
pounds she says she'll pay for that
through economic growth are you worried
that higher interest rates will dampen
that growth and she won't be able to pay
for these promises no interest rates
should have been raised a long time ago
and the bank of England has been too
slow in this regard interest rates have
are really important gravitational pull
on uh the value of assets and it's
really important to curb inflation so
actually it's very welcome that the bank
of England is increasing interest rates
now but what we really need to do and
this is why Liz it has got the right
plan for dealing with the cost of living
challenges is that we've got to ensure
that we re review the bank of England's
mandate she's very interested in looking
at how the bank of England operates
maintaining its independence of course
but also ensuring that it's much better
placed and more responsive in the future
to economic challenges like this that
like the type we're seeing at the moment
the challenge that we're facing the
moment is the fight against Global
inflation raising interest rates is a
lever that the bank of England has in
that fight reducing public spending is
another and cutting taxes so that
families and businesses can grow their
way out of the challenges as is a very
important step forward and that's why
Liz is the standout candidate for me
because she's forthright on the absolute
need to cut taxes but cutting taxes is
inflationary cutting taxes is going to
be very important for families so uh
when we look at the customer many
families will be welcoming the idea of
tax cuts but it'll allow them to spend
more money it's inflation well not
necessarily because actually what we're
going to see if we do lower the tax
burden no don't forget we've got a the
highest tax burden in 70 years people
say we can't afford to cut taxes Liz
thinks and I agree with her that we
can't afford not to cut taxes uh if we
cut taxes we're going to free up
businesses to invest more in their
research and development employ more
people lower their costs and that's only
going to be good for the economy they're
going to generate more Revenue to the
exchequer that's going to generate more
economic growth and therefore we have
more to invest in our Public Services
cutting taxes is the necessary step to
take and that's why Liz is the right
person to lead us through these economic
challenges another quick bit of detail
on the bank of England how are you going
to reform the bank of England you want
you want to give them more Powers you
want to get them fewer Powers I'm
confused well the list trust has made
clear that she wants to review the
Mandate that the bank of England so what
does that have so that's going to be
looking in detail at exactly what the
bank of England does and see whether
it's actually a fit for purpose in terms
of it's uh and entire exclusionary
Independence over interest rates the
last time this was done was in 1997 it's
right and it's ripe now to review
whether that is the right settlement
when it comes to our monetary policy of
course that's not to take away the bank
of England's Independence but there are
very uh there are many other models
around the world where central banks
have different uh degrees of
Independence over monetary policy for
example Japan is a country which we're
looking and I know that Liz is very very
keen on radical reform to ensure that
monetary policy can be much better
placed and more responsive to uh to to
inflationary pressures but also economic
challenges the NHS Confederation we
spoke to the chairman this morning has
sent letters to Liz truss and Rishi
sunag calling on them to spend more time
on their campaign talking about the
Health Service why is this being so
absent from Liz truss's campaign why has
this not been a big priority well don't
think it has been absent I think having
watched some of the debates and hustings
between Liz and Rishi I think it's all
almost always come up as a question but
not necessarily policy is forthcoming on
that subject and Liz truss is abandoning
the National Insurance rise the money
was supposed to go towards the Health
Service well again I mean this is about
a combination of uh stewardship of our
economy in a responsible way so cutting
taxes as we talked about earlier but
also delivery of public services and Liz
is absolutely clear that we are going to
stand by our 2019 Manifesto commitments
so the new hospitals ensuring that
people get access to a GP face-to-face
ensuring that there is better patient
flow through our a e by enabling better
primary care and reforming social care
we all know well many of us know that
it's painful it's heartbreaking and it's
incredibly difficult these days if
you've got an elderly relative and
you're trying to navigate the care where
the Labyrinth fine process of getting a
continuing Healthcare package it
shouldn't be that way and that's why Liz
will be introducing uh major reforms to
ensure that there's more Equity when it
comes to affording social care for
elderly relatives but also enabling
better delivery of primary care so that
is a an absolute a non-negotiable basic
uh tenet of Liz's campaign okay and and
I do want to get you to get your views
on a subject as attorney general
um about Archie Battersby
um the 12 year old his family have been
fighting to keep him on life support his
mother Holly dance I said last night it
feels wrong that the court of appeal
have taken away our rights do parents in
this country in your view have enough
rights when it comes to the care of
their children
well first of all I must just put whole
record my deepest uh sympathies for the
family of Archie matters B I cannot
begin to imagine what uh he and his
family have been going through
um this is a an incredibly uh
heartbreaking situation and everybody is
watching uh as uh the the parents and
the family try uh uh relentlessly to uh
look after and do the best by their son
any parent I'm sure would try to do the
same this has been this has gone through
the English courts
um and a decision was made by our
Supreme Court a few days ago not to
Grant permission to appeal and uh
following that as I understand it the
family applied to the European Court of
human rights to seek an intervention
from the strasbour court that was
declined by the European Court of Human
Rights it's not for me to uh look behind
those decisions of independent courts
but of course this is heartbreaking this
is incredibly sad and my thoughts go to
the family but but as a general rule
aside from this case do parents have
enough rights over the care of their
children do you think I think generally
we have a very important balance to
strike in this country uh I think
generally yes parents do have uh
sufficient rights the legal presumption
is that parents are acting in the best
interest of their children until and or
unless proved otherwise and I think that
generally the best interest of the child
are the guiding theme in any of these
decisions and parents will be best place
to understand what the best interest of
their child in in highly complex both
legally and morally issues like these
ones there are very many different
competing factors like medical opinion
and the value of clinical intervention
that has to be weighed against the the
parents wishes as well and many other
factors in in these cases these are not
straightforward they're highly highly
complex matters involving uh tell issues
of medicine and medical ethics as well
as the child's welfare and I have
confidence that our courts and our
judges will have looked at these issues
incredibly thoroughly incredibly
sensitively and have reached the right
decision
and finally Before I Let You Go let me
just quickly ask you about tonight's
debate on Sky News what can we expect
from Liz truss what does she have to do
listen I'm incredibly proud and excited
to be supporting Liz to be the leader of
our party and the next prime minister
she's proven time and time again that
she's experienced that she delivers and
that she's got a bold and Bright Vision
for our United Kingdom she is performing
incredibly well I was just speaking to
party members yesterday evening about
Liz's candidature the response is very
very positive people are coming to Liz
in their droves not just MPS but also
that's a nice debate we're all receive
from her I think we're going to see
typical Liz we're going to see bright
bold exciting Liz who can who who's
going to set out a a bold vision for our
country supporting families and
businesses with the cost of living
cutting taxes taking a Firm Stance on
brexit promises and delivering for the
country